[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feet I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from overthrow New York and lower
Manhattan where I'm joined by a familiar
face
Eddie Huang is here last time I did your
show I took a [ __ ] and burned my dick oh
[ __ ] this is no joke go to the bathroom
yeah yeah yeah dude that was so painful
I puked in the sink
I took a giant hot [ __ ] and then I
accidentally touched my dick so now my
dicks on fire well today is here to
exact his revenge red overthrow where he
trains regularly with professional boxer
Edgar Santana today I find out the hard
way who packs a bigger punch Blair's
Megadeth sauce or the human Panda I have
a sneaking suspicion it's the human
being who's going to hit him with the
hot [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not actually have to exert some
energy good yeah here's that yet
[Music]
I want you back of the head
dad mom dad
[Music]
what you call miss again I wish I wish
it could have good up you lasted 45 days
the winner by technical knockout the
human Panda 30 30 30 seconds or a second
yeah yeah everything I am everything I
lost and I'll tell that real because I
was so redlining yeah for those any no
all right you want to the hard 38
seconds mama die here I'm your grandpa
I'm your guy
I don't know about you I'm in the mood
for a post-workout meal oh I got you we
can go eat the spiciest hot pot in
Queens and if you take a [ __ ] you're
dead all right
Eddie brought us out to Flushing fly yo
so we're at the sky view center mall and
this is my favorite hot spot little lamb
there's a lot of lamb hotpot joints with
lamb or sheep in the title you want
little lamb at the sky you settle for
the real yeah also let's recognize the
footwear Oh
[Music]
I'm a hot pot in these Gucci flip-flops
you already know words so we're going to
get hot pot and as uranium go which
means you get like two soups in it one's
going to be spicy then one we're going
to do the Mongolian herbal broth usually
I would do the medium spicy but because
you're here we really really want to hit
you with the hot [ __ ] crank up we're
going to go extra spicy
alright and then for us if we don't want
that spies we got the safe one you're
going to eat all the extra hot no
because of what you've done in the
community okay okay I thought we were
even morning was about our fair fair
fair all right you want to go medium
spicy they're gonna try really yeah cuz
I don't have any boy in that hat ya know
what I'm saying extra spice is not even
enjoyable you know I mean users end up
like Coolio this night passed out sorry
we're going to go medium spicy my la
spicy broth in a Mongolian herbal broth
all right I like to get lamb and beef
lamb really has a great flavor with this
so we got the selected fatty Lam son
volume lamb prime beef short rib assist
you got the corporate card and I see you
got more cameras this year even while
you be 54 54 99 yo you know spend this
money then we're going to get into the
offal
right this is the stuff you need it the
beef tripe you know some duck flippers
it's good I'll go with that
is he just a Dolittle Duffy I got it
yeah here we go
thank you it's a strong order yeah very
strong water oh I should take you to
make some sauces we'll make this off
yeah the sausage is very key to that yo
so this is where hot pot is won or lost
all right we had a strong order right
very strong order right you kinda break
it if the sauces aren't right yeah
because they have so many options and
there's also traps here right like when
we're boxing you got like a strong light
right you had a strong order strong
right but I could set you a trap wrap
invite them that right and might fight
angry sauces they said anywhere apps
yeah so there's some things here like
plum sauce
hi like there's a couple things maybe
one point possible for what we ordered
you don't want that you put that in your
sauce you're in trouble
so I will give you this is the classic
sauce the people in Chen do make it's
not too many ingredients very simple i
sesame oil right there garlic a good
amount of garlic moister sauce but you
may not expect it gives it body cilantro
very simple a lot of cilantro it gives
you some scallions there's your basic
sauce this will go with everything and
it mixes really well with the flavor in
the hot pot so we knew we're going to
grab a meal is there a reason that we're
getting hot pot specifically after
boxing or we just grabbing a meal the
reason why I chose how fun is because
how hot is one of those food experiences
that's very easy to catch a brick like
the sauces are tricky to maneuver the
menus hard the maneuver for people that
don't speak Chinese didn't grow up in a
Chinese background or you know East
Asian hotpot is kind of tricky to enjoy
but it's one of my favorite things to
eat and also like after boxing you just
want to eat
[Music]
these tribes usually the first thing I
like to put into the hot pot because
beef try give the soup stock a lot of
flavor it's a quick cook you can almost
like instant reaction to yeah unless
right I love noodle okay we can go like
a diamond like nobody in Detroit
yeah I love tripe eating it for texture
as much as flavor you know that tripe is
good today and will snap be impressed we
caught him on again try yeah we caught
him on a real good track there oh yeah I
mean now we just we just going in now
we're just going in this is my brother's
innovation right he likes to do a
staging boat so he staged it in there
then dip it in sauce they eat it off the
plate and then this is ribeye you really
some things here and so that's lamb so
use your lamb sauce that's your lamb
sauce right here
mix mix up the sauce first and then dip
it in okay
yeah it'll get better as you go to
because the stock will start to sit with
your sauce tripe would you think by the
time I tried was great the lamb is my
favorite so far
this is good today this is like spicy
for flavor knowledge I shouldn't kill
you you know it's funny that we're here
eating hotpot after just beating the
[ __ ] out of each other and the boxing
ring and it has me thinking about all
the ways that food media has changed
food has become sort of background
character in these sorts of experiences
and I wonder what your take is yeah I
see your show is probably my favorite
internet show because it is an interview
show with the light wing challenge
because people are eating hot sauce
they're scared for their lives their
bodies are going through something you
get more honestly you know and that's
what I think makes it a great show on
ones where we get people moving active
eating food and then they start to open
up a little bit more I think the same
way you know like I don't think anybody
makes a food show really anymore I think
that they make people shows everybody
that has come to this format has
something that they're trying to say and
they're trying to do in a question that
they're trying to unravel 20 Bourdain
candidates with a cook store and no
reservation and I think in a lot of ways
Tony wanted to find something real and
because of his journey because of his
experience it makes it easier for people
watching to say hey like it shouldn't be
so intimidating it shouldn't be so
challenging if he can do it I can do it
you know I came to the food travel space
with a very specific agenda in mind
because I had spent a lot of my life as
a kind of silence minority in America
right
hey ching chong Harry Wong yada yada and
because of my skin because of my eyes it
really limited who people in my
community allowed me to be but then I
came to New York in New York is where I
became a man New York is where I learned
to like really love myself because New
Yorkers accept you for all your weird
idiosyncrasies and New York to me was a
little like Epcot we learned so much
from each other as New Yorkers just
visiting like singular blocks of an
entire continent or culture in the East
Village or in Queens I said what if we
expanded is we travel around the world
and use food as an equalizer so people
can understand for all of our
differences were more similar than we
aren't different and that was like the
singular purpose of lols room that's
what I'm trying to do and I think that's
a big enough question for five or six
seasons right right you know Neil the
diss mana tea oh thank you thank you
thank you you give a vet used on Wong's
world you've done on the running here
and now you're doing in the wild with
Shaun what'd you think about the food
shows be kind of a new experience right
you know I've never I've never saw
formed like
the way I'm seeing it now I feel food as
a different parties different dad like I
just do all hip norris exact sorta told
the story like that just like just like
you start barking really know the signs
of the box of [ __ ] now you want us know
you know while you sleep in this way to
fight the lit punch I saw Eddie
people's chance was it at all Qatar Nick
knocking me around in the ring well I
mean why did you have fun doing it yes I
had a lot of fun you know I saw your
face at a certain point about you know
20 seconds in Oz is not going to last
that long so get your licks in because
you know Sean may run out of breath here
but every time I spar even today with
you you get a little nervous before you
like you I may get punched in the face I
saw you warming up with that right here
is like if I'm not focused I want to
catch him right here okay I did not
catch any ha ha 0 for 0 but like you
know I mean like I love you but you
definitely bodied me on hot ones a lot
of people have kind of [ __ ] up on this
show so I feel like just needed you yeah
I had to be for the people for the
people
yeah this was for 2 people Eddie thank
you so much for bringing me out to lunch
the least that I can do is extend the
plug after the training them to be back
beating anyone you can catch them on
vice land Long's world's season 2 its
back Wednesday's 10:00 p.m. Eastern
thank you so much my man thank you for
having us appreciate it
you want to Train Santana boxing on
Instagram
[Music]
[Music]